[Musique]
en contexte de crise sanitaire il
important de respecter certaines règles
et consignes d'hygiène et de sécurité
nous allons vous expliquer comment
mettre correctement un masque dans les
situations qui sont indiqués et comment
respecter l'hygiène des mains avant et
après le port du masque pour toute
manipulation de masse qu il est
important de respecter les gestes
d'hygiène des mains
cela peut se faire avec de l'eau et du
savon ou avec une solution ou un gel
hydroalcoolique
il est important de penser à bien
frictionner les deux paumes des mains
ne pas oublier de faire également entre
les doigts les ongles et les poignets
ces gestes doivent être répétés jusqu'à
ce que les mains soient sèches et que la
solution soit bien imprégné au niveau de
la peau prenez le masque le bord rigide
vers le haut et la face colorées vers
l'extérieur placez le sur le visage en
le tenant par les lacets ou les
élastiques passé les élastiques
derrière chaque oreille
vincee le haut du masque sur la racine
du nez a baissé le bas du masque sous le
menton à partir de cet instant ne
portait plus les mains sur votre masque
changer le après quatre heures où dès
qu'il est mouillé avant retrait
frictionner à nouveau les mains avec une
solution hydro alcoolique ou à défaut
lavez vous les mains avec de l'eau et du
savon ôtez le masque uniquement par les
élastiques et sans toucher l'ensemble du
masque ni la face coloré celle ci
pourrait être contaminantes jeté le
masque dans une poubelle ou une filière
disponible de déchets puis lavez vous à
nouveau les mains ou utiliser une
solution hydroalcoolique
si on ne respecte pas les consignes
l'utilisation du masque on peut
effectivement être contaminants du fait
de toucher le masque pendant son
utilisation ou de ne pas le porter
correctement il faut bien penser à
protéger le nez sous le menton et de
respecter aussi la durée d'utilisation
du masque
[Musique]